this is my church you know I run out
here in this beautiful nature created by
some higher power it is absolutely
gorgeous I feel so connected to life the
environment nature myself everything all
beings and so forth love the whole thing
and realizing there is no whether I get
1st 5th 25th nobody can take away the
experience I'm having right now in
nature do feeling this fit feeling this
alive and that's what I tell a lot of my
athletes to this day don't let anybody
rob you of your joy and journey in
nature training and doing this every day
that's self-care that's very protected
time every day you deserve that not only
will others benefit from it but also
that's your precious precious time and
don't let anything rob you of that
opportunity every day to go inside
yourself and exhale yeah that's the
experience that I want everybody to have
exactly you know it's it's it's a sense
of feeling connected to yourself of
feeling alive of being connected to
nature and your environment in in a way
that I don't know any other way to
achieve that other than to be actively
engaged with my body in that way I mean
meditation a variety of other ways to
alter your mind whether it's you know
ayahuasca or immersion tanks there's so
many ways these days but one of the ways
for me is training out in nature
immersing myself truly in nature or just
daily you know not always am i running
in the woods and it's this idyllic scene
trust me I'm gonna treadmill every now
and then too but at least closing my
eyes and resetting myself and saying
listening to my body hearing that heart
rate and that heavy breathing and just
going okay there we go I'm back to the
true setting my evolutionary self yeah
even just for 30 seconds a day because
it takes a while to reset that every day
right
to finally have the mind clear and get
to a point where it's like alright there
we go and everybody I know everybody has
experienced some sort of reset before
and where they whether you take a long
shower and you come out invigorated or
it's exercise or it's meditation or it's
just a great night's sleep or sitting
somewhere on a rock overlooking
something or the beach there's so many
ways everyday that we have an
opportunity to sort of take a deep
breath reset and find ourselves and say
alright well I got this that like you
said we can connect that to as many
people as possible that's that's it
mm-hmm so with this evolution that
you've been on how has that impacted
your your like down stream how you
interact with and coach your athletes
like what has changed in how you create
programs and communicate with your
athletes versus perhaps what you might
have done five or ten years ago well
five or ten years ago is more
outcome-based I can help you achieve X
qualifier or this time or this result
and now it's more about the process the
journey I want to get you out there
doing it I want to help you achieve not
only what you're curious about but also
help you navigate through it all so that
you can stay in some sort of balance
right we have family we have worked we
have our own self-care if we can take
those three and somewhat keep those all
those balls juggled in the air at the
same time then we're really getting to
that version of ourselves that we're
really happy with maybe not the best
version of ourselves but a pretty good
outcome of that and there's gonna be
times where of course work and
professional life takes a bigger balance
bigger part share of the balance right
doesn't mean we stop training it doesn't
mean we stop exercising it just means we
have less hours available or we pick and
choose our windows when we train a lot
more strategically or there's times
where family and career take on a bigger
role and
you know navigating through that that's
what I work I want to work with my
athletes most on right and they're open
to that growth and they're open to that
exploration in the meantime a lot of my
newer athletes who are who say you know
what I want to figure this out and I
want to work with you in order to figure
it do you ever come across like a clone
of a younger version of you who's like I
don't hear about that I just
I'm here to qualify for Kona just give
me the full head I do yeah I do come
across this but the beauty is there they
actually sort of get it too they might
not like fully embrace it but they get
that this is about balancing and
longevity if great you make it to Kona
this year but if you do this wrong I can
already tell them you know I've been
where you've been in your late 20s early
30s Kona's everything and you're gonna
be done in two years because you can't
keep burning that match the way you are
right right
whereas if you care about doing this for
many years and really want to get to the
top of Kona which you're not gonna do in
your first year or your second year we
have to do this in balance early on and
then you've got a couple years to really
hit your potential there and that they
do get and I would have even in back of
my day
understood that somewhat mm-hmm if
somebody told me that in working with
the group of athletes that you've worked
with what is the consistent challenge
that kind of comes up across the board
or complaint or or barrier that people
are confronted with that you have to
help them through yeah this is an easy
one the hardest part of being a coach is
communication
the athletes willingness to communicate
with me of all things
uh-huh because the more I'm armed with
their communication the better of a plan
we can write together right because it
is we write it together you give me your
limiters you give me your challenges
your schedules your stresses and I can
work a plan around that and then you say
well this doesn't work on I'll have a
soccer game on Saturday and my daughter
does this on Sunday
all right well let's get up at 5:00 and
get those two hours done there and then
in the afternoon stresses off your table
your unstressed about joining the soccer
game or going to the gymnastics meet or
doing this because we got it done but
you're gonna have to go to bed
you know before 1:00 a.m. on Saturday so
there's a give-and-take so managing that
and then the other aspect of
communication of how they're feeling
what they're observing like being
vulnerable to this guy yeah on the other
end right and we know it from being
coached all our lives
right we were coached as young kids a
lot of people have been coached before
and it's one of my questions on when I
asked athletes have you been coached
before because knowing how to be coached
to open yourself up to allow yourself to
be coached is very very different than
just receiving a plan mm-hmm right we
had the luck and the the joy actually of
coaches who were on deck and can see us
every day her mood her impatience her
crankiness our fatigue right our body
weight all that when it's though all
those things were indicators and this
guy might be a going a bit over the edge
or he might need a recovery week or well
they didn't have a career such thing as
that but you learn to communicate feel
exactly and you're so in touch with your
body that you have you develop this
language for expressing where you're at
and I think that's new and different for
people that are coming into it later
exactly and I see that in the logs right
like the way that people communicate
with them and they're like well I hit
these power numbers but I'd miss this
it's like yeah I already see that from
the data I want to know like you know
how it felt what did you do versus how
did it feel versus last week this is
your heart rates are a little off what's
going on here are there other stresses
in your life did you have dinner last
night you should have been able to crush
these intervals why did you feel like
that right oh yeah I skipped dinner I
was where I worked late and came home
family time and next thing I know I had
maybe only a bar right well of course
now we're getting into now it all makes
sense now I can actually coach that
athlete and let them know don't be
so hard on yourself on how that work out
when look it's very clear here on why it
didn't work that way right and then
their confidence is boosted of course
because now it all makes sense if they
didn't tell me that in four weeks from
now they're completely completely upset
about their training mm-hmm right
because they don't understand why it's
going so bad but we haven't broken into
everything that they can fix very easily
to be successful with this